parts of the southwestern US are bracing
for possible flash flooding from
tropical depression Rossa as it moves in
from Mexico downpours are expected to
move across Arizona all day today and
into tomorrow southern and central
Arizona could have as much as four
inches of rain today Carter Evans is in
Goodyear Arizona where it's been raining
all night Carter good morning good
morning that rain is really just getting
going right now this is the Agua Fria
river bed this is one of those areas
that can flood very quickly when they
get a lot of rain in a very short period
of time and that's what they're
expecting the National Hurricane Center
says the rain could be so heavy at times
that there could be life threatening
flash flooding there could also be
mudslides and landslides in the foothill
areas now in Tucson on Monday about a
hundred miles south of here
the rain flooded streets and it's not
just the rain forecasters say winds
could be a tropical storm levels and
these photos show the damage Monday in
Baja California hit with as much as six
inches of rain meanwhile government
officials in Mexico are investigating
reports that a man was swept to his
death in these floodwaters in Sonora in
the wake of tropical storm Rosa now the
rain is expected to last through
Wednesday possibly even into Thursday
here in the Phoenix area in the next 24
hours they're expected to get more rain
than they've had in the last two months
Gale all right thank you very much
Carter